[Musique]
on a découvert
euh avec l'aide du public euh
la première détection
en décembre
[Musique]
et ce que ça veut dire pour nous c'est qu'au
moins l'un d'entre eux
euh est passé par euh pour produire des
castings reproducteurs et il peut y avoir  200 à 300 reines
expulsées et certaines d'entre elles réussiront,
c'est donc quelque chose dont nous nous
attendions à ce qu'il y ait
probablement plus que celui-ci
[Music] [
Music]
euh [
euh
[Music]
actuellement dans le comté de Whatcom avec l'
aide  du grand public
[musique]
les clubs d'abeilles et le
département de l'agriculture de l'état de washington
nous avons plus de 1800 je pense que cela pourrait même
être plus de 2 000 pièges j'ai trois pièges
sur ma propriété ici
et puis j'ai quatre autres pièges sur la propriété de mon
voisin
[Musique]
nous avons une population de reproducteurs reproducteurs,
l'enlèvement du nid est essentiel
car
s'il réussit et hiverne,
il peut produire
plus de reines qui pourraient créer plus de nids
l'année suivante
[Musique]
les éradiquer c'est aussi horrible que
cela puisse paraître c'est  notre objectif
est de les tuer et de les empêcher d'
établir l'état de Washington,
vous